maintenant nous partons à la découverte
d'une école ou d'une formation dans les
Yvelines Régine radèche ce soir vous
allez nous parler du centre de formation
des métiers du bâtiment et des travaux
publics de qui se situe à Trappes tout à
fait Mathilde cette semaine on part à la
découverte des métiers du bâtiment et
c'est une branche dont on parle peu et
qui pourtant recrute énormément alors en
quelques mots le CFM BTP c'est un CFA
donc un centre de formation d'apprenti
il a été créé en 1976 dans la ville
d'orsement dans les Yvelines et ce
spécialise comme son nom l'indique dans
les métiers du bâtiment et des travaux
publics alors il propose plusieurs
niveaux de diplôme on a le titre
professionnel le cap le BP et le BTS en
ce qui concerne les filières donc on a
la filière du bâtiment et la filière des
travaux publics les bâtiments donc ça va
être la construction de maison
d'appartements de d'édifice et en ce qui
concerne le les travaux publics alors
les travaux publics faut savoir que
c'est plutôt des chantiers qui sont
commandés par les pouvoir public ou des
grandes entreprises comme par exemple
Vinci ou Eiffage et donc du coup on va
plutôt parler de travaux routiers par
exemple ou de réseaux de canalisations
et quel métier peut-on faire suite à ces
formations alors c'est très varié on
peut parler de maçon on peut aussi
devenir peintre ou être étancheur donc
c'est un métier que je ne connaissais
pas du tout donc le métier d'étancheur
qui consiste justement à mettre en place
en tout cas à vérifier l'étanchéité d'un
ouvrage pour éviter justement tout ce
qui infiltration de d'humidité d'eau et
donc pour en parler avec nous Julien
Guillerm alors vous êtes étudiant en
deuxième année de bts quel est le
parcours que vous avez suivi
moi j'ai commencé par un cap Masson qui
est une formation sur deux ans où j'ai
appris le à monter du bloc à
brancher
construire un voile et j'ai poursuivi
après sur un bac pro tibergo qui déjà
s'oriente un peu plus sur de la gestion
de chantier mais qui reste quand même un
peu plus
terrain pratique et là je suis
actuellement en BTS bâtiment qui est là
du coup complètement de la direction de
chantier en tout cas pour le poste que
j'occupe
et donc aujourd'hui vous êtes en
alternance chez bouygues Bâtiment à
Guyancourt ce que vous pouvez vous nous
raconter un peu vos missions en
alternance alors l'émission au sein de
Bouygues sont assez variés moi j'occupe
un poste d'assistant chef de chantier
donc ça va être principalement de la
gestion d'équipe de la gestion de
chantier ça va être du traçage regardez
si les équipes ne manquent de rien
prévoir d'éventuelles commandes et
pouvoir interagir aussi avec les
différents fournisseurs et différents
clients est-ce que c'est difficile de
trouver une alternance justement dans ce
secteur
c'est un métier qui recrute énormément
après qui est à mon sens c'est
l'alternance dans le bâtiment est pas
encore assez connu au sein des
entreprises qui est un peu dommage
mais
c'est on va dire un métier qui moi une
situation qui permet oui de recruter par
la suite et alors quels sont les
courses du centre de formation des
métiers du BTP
dans votre filière bâtiment par exemple
en BTS là on a des cours qui s'orientent
via un milieu qui veut être scientifique
on a de la mécanique on va nous
apprendre ajustement expliquer
comprendre le support d'une charge
affection ça résistance au béton ou à la
ferraille aux différentes intempéries et
on a aussi des cours on nous apprend à
nous exprimer à avoir une éloquence et
toujours des des cours
théoriques sur l'installation de
chantier de la gestion de chantier et de
la gestion d'équipe comment est-ce qu'on
centre de formation c'est via parcoursup
alors on peut l'intégrer via parcoursup
directement sur la plateforme en
cherchant CFM BTP moi pour ma part étant
déjà sur dans l'établissement c'était
plus une formalité
de continuation et si vous deviez donner
un conseil à un lycéen ou un étudiant en
réorientation qui aimerait rentrer dans
cette école vous lui diriez quoi
de pas avoir peur et de foncer
honnêtement c'est une formation qui est
qui est riche en apprentissage et qui
permet aussi pour les jeunes ce qui est
pas négligeable d'obtenir un salaire du
coup vu que c'est de l'alternance et de
se former un métier en même temps qui
est à mon sens déjà un gros avantage le
jour de l'ange par rapport à l'employeur
qui préférera choisir quelqu'un qui a
justement une filière apprentissage et
justement aujourd'hui on voit que c'est
très varié en termes de métier est-ce
que vous avez déjà une idée de ce que
vous souhaitez faire à la sortie de vos
études
pour le moment j'occupe du coup un poste
d'assistant chef de chantier dans l'idée
ça serait de d'être embauché en CDI avec
ma société dans ce poste là et après
évoluer en tant que chef de chantier
dire les échelons et c'est justement un
secteur je pense d'avenir est-ce que
comment
comment est-ce qu'on peut amener
justement les étudiants à s'intéresser à
cette filière puisqu'on parle beaucoup
de rénovation énergétique il y a
beaucoup de choses à faire je pense dans
les années à venir est-ce que à votre
avis les étudiants aujourd'hui sont au
courant de tous ces enjeux comment
est-ce qu'on peut les amener justement à
s'intéresser à ces à ces métiers
à mon sens ça serait peut-être important
de faire des des journées portes
ouvertes nous en tout cas dans ma
société on en organise avec des écoles
où on a des futurs potentiels apprentis
qui viennent visiter les chantiers on
leur explique un peu le métier et les
tâches que en tant qu'apprenti on
réalise et les tâches que du coup nos
supérieurs embauchés réalisent et
voilà pour moi ça serait pas mal de
diversifier un peu ce côté là pour
apporter un support on va dire visuel en
plus du de ce qu'on peut raconter sur
les formations
j'imagine que les écoles aussi donc font
beaucoup de portes ouvertes parce que je
pense qu'elles sont au courant qu'il y a
une pénurie en tout cas dans le
recrutement est-ce que pour vous comment
si vous devriez vendre cfmbtp quel
serait son point fort selon vous quel
est son point fort
pour moi son point fort en tout cas ce
qui m'a plu
dans ce CFA c'est que ces diversifié au
niveau de la déformation qu'on peut
avoir ça va du CAP au BTS et on peut
avoir une continuité de filière comme
moi je suis resté dans le gros homme en
commençant par un cap Masson en faisant
un bac et un BTS qui est la continuité
justement du gros œuvre donc je pense
que le point fort c'est justement cette
diversification des diplômes et bien
merci beaucoup Julien Guillaume d'être
venu parler de votre de votre école en
plateau